from seeing indie game the movie which
was fantastic and I don't know too much
about the game of the world but just
seeing how I mean they put everything
into this and it was not just money and
time it was just like that's who they
were yeah and is that typical the two of
you I mean it sounds like you you really
this is your passion and you live and
breathe it 24-7 you know I had a career
and a really wonderful coaching practice
that I was building when I decided I
think he needs help because we call him
the hacker on the hustler I go and I
talk to people and I'll tell you we've
been together for 17 years before this
started so we're now just passed in 18
years gradual I love my husband but I
tell you there was a time last December
where I thought I don't know if our
marriage can handle this anymore because
you are working twenty-four/seven with
that person and you put your head down
on the pillow and it's like all you talk
about his work and you forget about the
husband and the wife you forget about
that partner you forget about that love
because you're so focused especially in
a start-up where you're constantly
worrying about payroll and god bless her
hurt the people that we've worked with
they really have they've made huge
sacrifices to do that with us so it's
everybody's in the same boat of making
that sacrifice it's very stressful very
very stressful I wouldn't recommend it
no well um do you ever take a break for
yourself even if it's a half hour
because if you if and for anybody who
has done something where they're the
soul sort of engine behind it you feel
guilty mm-hmm taking a break in even if
you read a book that sort of gear tort
you feel like I'm playing I'm goofing
off what do you do to kind of have down
time i will say netflix has been my
Savior okay nice we want a lot of murder
mysteries together we're very creepy
that way we like those like fantastic
norwegian noir movies and in series
where the most bizarre things happen and
that's our down time I mean last year we
were in the office probably from 9am
till 11pm every night seven days a week
Wow
I think that's what was nearly our
undoing now we go home at five-thirty
we'll have dinner and then we'll
probably continue working but we've
taken that time out and we try to take
the weekends off too but that never
happens well there's that saying that
entrepreneurs live like most people
won't so that yeah the woman
paraphrasing where where to eventually
get to a place where most people can't
how long would you say I mean there's
probably no set time limit it sounds
like you had to do that said yeah week
14 where we're just about to break
through the damn oh great okay we've
reached out to some very incredible
influential people they're taking us
very seriously and I can't wait to be
able to say we're working with them
because I think that's part of the pond
it's game over at that point you know I
have enjoyed sorry I have a little bit
of a cough I've enjoyed working with my
husband it's been amazing to watch and
be a leader I've never seen that part of
him before and but I'm really tired of
bootstrapping bootstrapping where you
just take enough to cover your rent and
the minimum credit card payments because
we put everything into this our entire
lives our entire savings but I don't
regret it and that's interesting that
you say that because i was reading a
book about or sees me a medium article
about loneliness and entrepreneurs and
because you have such tunnel vision kind
of stuff around you falls apart and it's
not because you mean it too it's just
because you haven't put the attention
yeah so advice for others that are going
through that and also really kind of
asking yourself do you really want it
because this you have to be willing to
give up everything to do this this isn't
entrepreneurship is not a part-time job
it is a full-on commitment and it's
going to take you know all of those
books say it'll take you twice as long
as you think and i was one of those
people no not us not us will be you know
hit all of our deadline no no we we got
tripped up and we lost a little bit of
time and but we just we can we continue
to do it and there's a point where you
worry about where that money is
come from but what they say and what I
have found to be true when you are
living your passion people see that
people will walk up to you because they
see that you're engaged you know what
you're talking about you've done your
research the more and more that we have
progressed in the business and gotten
clear about the vision and the product
and all of that and what our gift is to
writers the more people get it so we're
finally at that stage where people are
like yeah we said earlier that some
people are taking you seriously but it
sounds like you took yourselves
seriously for 20 months oh yeah and
that's where the payoff because a lot of
people wouldn't probably put that much
time I you know there was one person in
particular who said how is it that you
fly all over the place and that's easy I
gave up a car I live in a tiny apartment
I live well below our means I made those
sacrifices because this was more
important to me and I know that in the
long run no matter what happens with the
company everybody who's done the work
will benefit from it somehow you know
whether they get a better job or this
thing takes off and maybe we'll all be
millionaires that would be really
fantastic but we're all better people
because of the hard work that we've put
into it
you